Joe Biden losing his Riz as his brain
goes Fizz Democrats crapping their pants
over new polls and show young voters
flocking to Donald Trump a group Joe won
by 20 points in 2020 latest Fox polls
have the uh former president leading
Biden among voters under the age of 30
just look at that Joe thinking the best
way to win him back is by sitting down
with Conan to talk about his hair if you
stay connected to these things that
embarrassed you when you were a kid
whatever it was speech impediment or
anxiety or feeling awkward or not being
a good athlete I my list goes on and on
and on um having weird hair having a
weird name I wish you had your hair I'd
trade right now if you want you want
this hair it comes off it's a it's it's
it Velcro on the back yeah if I could do
it I would do it I will I will mail you
this wig tomorrow Joe could do it
actually kamla is also hitting the
airwaves to offer up this pearl of
wisdom on the election you know every
election cycle we talk about this is the
most election of our lifetime Lawrence
this one is I have been fortunate and
blessed that during the course of being
vice president have many situations
where it becomes clear to me that there
are you know people of every Age and and
gender by the way who see something
about being the first that lets them
know they don't need to be um limited by
other people's limited um understanding
of who can do what wow wow that was
amazing
Dana my I have two theories okay she's
drunk no okay then whatever Federman had
he
regifted I mean they have had some late
nights having to do the holiday party
you are too diplomatic she is high as a
k no I just think that this is actually
her numbers go up when she doesn't do
interviews yeah okay there's actually a
strategy to that like as you said presid
like just don't don't talk and your
numbers go up I was with a friend the
other night she's a Democrat she voted
for Biden Harris and she said what do
you think is the problem for Harris I'm
like I why I don't know how to explain
it switch to light beer don't know I
don't whatever she's drinking I don't
know if that is it they are that was not
sober I'm not drink shaming I'm just
saying I'm trying to give her an out
here because that made no sense I think
that well I think that this is very
reminiscent of all the other times she's
done interviews think about the space
interview right the Spy space and the
world word salad I can't remember that
one word she repeated 20 times in one
sentence the runon sentence um what I
thought was interesting is that Lawrence
O'Donnell didn't even try to help a
sister out he doesn't try to interrupt
and say Let me let me before you before
I let you go let me ask you one more
question that he thinks she can actually
nail yeah passage of time you know it's
weird it's like she's not learning on
the job she's unlearning on the job
which is a first Harold I want to go to
you I won't I'll try not to embarrass
you too much um do you think Young young
people are catching on that equity and
identity doesn't create a future that
pronouns don't lead to property you
can't raise a family on reparations and
an oppression filter do you think
they're catching on to the destructive
ideas of the democratic party that you
seem to defend every day as a known
communist oh my
God so investing in America is up prices
are coming down corporate corporate
profits are up every barometer corate
profits well I'm out of here corporate
profits up I don't know if that's the
best argument for the young people Hing
is up uh and we're going to find a way
to make the country better and if you're
a young woman and want your rights to go
to a doctor and a doctor be able to tell
you everything that doctor wants to tell
you how to vote Democrat if I were them
I'd be I'd be speaking my book I'd be
out pounding pounding away at why we
deserve four more years but if you're
constantly on defense and one last thing
they got to deal with the Border I I
agree with everybody around the border
is the one issue that can Trump no pun
intended could Trump the advantage of
Democrats have on Reproductive Rights
and access to a safe and and legal
abortion so I don't I I didn't dismiss
the numbers yesterday with Biden falling
those are not good numbers let me be
clear if you're in the White House and
I've said it before I don't know what
your strategy is I keep seeing these
awful numbers and I don't know what I
see the vice president I see others on
and no one is giving us a Litany of the
things you've done and why that's
connected to what you're going to do
going forward if you don't do that the
more Greg gutfeld's arguments are going
to be compelling and the more they're
going to connect with voters
particularly young voters speaking of
abortion you want to hear an abortion
joke I do not knock
knock who's there you'll never
know I'm not um not just it's a good
joke oldie but a goodie an oldie but a
goodie Jesse remember when Fallon got
all that grief for good-naturedly joking
with Trump about his hair think that'll
happen
here there will be a rebound with Trump
and the entertainment business there
will be there has to be just for the
money and the ratings but in the if
you're a young person in the 20s in 2016
if you were for Trump you were ahead of
the curve you were edgy you saw it
coming and Hillary was terrible so then
2020 happened and you had covid and
Trump was just getting slaughtered in
the media and there was a lot of Sops
and everybody was disconnected everybody
was
home and then
you get 2024 rolling around and Joe just
doesn't have the cool Factor kamla
doesn't have it the cities aren't cool
anymore everybody with cash left to the
BBS or Miami and rates are too high so
you don't see a future for yourself
you're like all right I got a pot of
money but I can't put it down in a house
because rates are at
7% and then the identity politics and
the gender stuff if you're a young guy
or even a young girl you're like this
this is just crazy especially with the
girls playing the boy Sports it's just
crazy and so now now you don't look at a
guy like Trump as this this kind of
radioactive and saying he's normal now
he's normal and Joe is The Nut Job who
is like can't walk yeah so that and then
K she's not an asset she was supposed to
be this like groovy asset that was young
and could get the Latino or black Vote
or the young voters how does groovy look
again she can't she can't pull it off
yeah and uh and and that's terrible no
one even knows who she is in the streets
you see Johnny no one's ever heard of
her yeah definitely all right uh to his
hear abortion joke yes knock knock all
right Emily there seems to be what Jesse
said clumsily and almost incoherently is
that there seems to be a flip going on
ahead yes that people who were once hip
are now crotchety and the people that
they used to make fun of for being out
of touch are now cool and interesting to
young people because they're rebelling
against this bizarre identity Conformity
and that the entire time what they
perceived as cool was a whole fce the
reason people don't know who kamla is is
because she doesn't know who she is this
is a total case of The Emperor's New
Clothes as we sit here watching her
engage in her word salad and her just
absolute lack of any sense whatsoever
those of us Common Sense Californians
who lived in San Francisco while she was
Da and in California while she was an
attorney general and then senator we've
seen this from the beginning she never
even passed the bar on the first it just
everything about her she failed the bar
on the first time yes she did the only
bar she didn't pass oh my God oh my God
unlike me that passed both bars in the
first try so the whole point is here's
someone that has been intellectually
unqualified and you either you know you
work hard or you're really smart and and
in her what have have we seen either
we've seen no accomplishments whatsoever
but the point is that this
Administration shoved down everyone's
throats why they should think she is hip
and cool and blasting through ceilings
and why Joe Biden was hip and cool and
should listen to the left but the fact
that they're not ideologues they are
just virtue signalers is now reflected
in everyone leaving so this New York
Times Sienna poll just this week this
July they voted overwhelmingly for Biden
over Trump 18 to 29 years old now
they're voting overwhelmingly for Trump
who do they trust more with Israel and
Palestine Trump how many percentage do
they find is disfavorable they look
disfavor upon the president overwhelming
majority almost 75%
because the whole point is he isn't
sticking to his guns he had no guns in
the first place he just said what he
thought they wanted to hear by propping
up a tick tocker by saying something
cool by saying really racist comments
that they sort of pushed under the rug
so at the end of the day we are seeing
him for his true stripes and KLA for
their true Stripes which is absolutely
worthless and Trump for his true Stripes
he's always been radical he's always
been not a politician that's what Drew
people to him in the first place and the
biggest difference too is he listened
mhm all right there you go take a breath
now Emily I can hi everyone I'm Brian
kilme I want you to do me a favor I want
you to click to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page this is the only way
that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now